les passagers du vol air france 017
échappé au pire y un matin que s'est il
passé hier à l'aéroport de roissy une
grosse frayeur en avion ils ont eu la
peur de leur vie alors que le boeing 777
en provenance de new york s'apprête à
atterrir sur la piste 26 de l'aéroport
roissy charles de gaulle à paris les
commandes de l'appareil ne répondent
plus alors que l'engin est à quelques
mètres de la piste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'avion va finir par à terre sur une
autre piste avec à bord des passagers
sains et saufs alors erreur humaine ou
problème technique sommes-nous toujours
en sécurité dans les avions
gérard feldzer qui est avec nous pilotes
de ligne et ingénieurs comment ça va
j'ai regardé j'ai été pilote de ligne
mais bien sûr oui pour moi vous serez
tout ça et aujourd'hui je suis président
de la vieille sans frontières mais c'est
une autre histoire elles sont dirigées
en moi quand on est pilote une fois on
est toujours pilote c'est comme quand on
est ministre girard qu'est ce qui s'est
passé là alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il ya eu une remise de gaz parce que on
a eu un bug dans les commandes de vol
c'est un avion moderne mauvaise série
pour boeing d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il ya
pas mal d'accidents mais en tous les cas
peut-être une un dysfonctionnement
informatique un bug informatique mais on
apprend aux pilotes à remettre les gaz
remise de gaz c'est quoi moi quand
j'étais instructeur avec mes pilotes de
ligne je leur disais le moindre doute
vous remettez les gaz et après on
réfléchit et si un blocage de commandes
on peut toujours les surpasser c'est ce
qui s'est passé
le problème c'est que c'est un
changement d'attitude les passagers ils
sont peinards ils veulent s'en sortir et
les volets atterrissage on est à deux
trois minutes de l'atterrissage et puis
tout d'un coup l'avion se cabre on met
plein pot on rentre le train ça fait du
bruit et pilotes il n'a pas le temps de
dire ce qui se passe donc il ya une
petite angoisse et un stress très
content andres est en tous les cas le
pilote lui pendant cette manoeuvre qui
dure cinq secondes en gros on dit il ya
un échange entre le pilote et le
commandant de bord en disant on va
essayer de comprendre d'abord on
sauvegarde la procédure et ensuite on va
analyser ce qui se passe c'est ce qui
s'est passé alors comment il s'entraîne
alors au miso gave et bien trois fois
par an on passe quatre heures dans un
simulateur et on fait des remises de gad
systématique alors je disais à mes
élèves toujours back to basics ça veut
dire si vous comprenez pas ce qui se
passe vous le reprenez à la main c'est
ce qui s'est passé ils l'ont repris à la
main et ça parce qu'on peut toujours
surpassé le pilote automatique on entend
un bruit un moment alors on va en libye
ouais c'est quoi alors c'est pilote
automatique est déconnecté accord c'est
pour prévenir l'équipage soit le pilote
automatique dit je n'ai pas les bonnes
informations je te rond l'avion tu te
débrouilles soit il est déconnecté par
les pilotes et on entend la même alarme
c'est fou alors sur les réseaux sociaux
via une vidéo qui comporte un
enregistrement du dialogue très
stressant de l'équipage avec la tour de
contrôle des chiens charles de gaulle de
roissy sur le web qui a été publié
regardez un enregistrement qui montrent
surtout le sang froid des piles à
écouter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va les maintenir
patoux 6 euros maintenant qu'apple pied
le cannage cet ami greg le départ d'or
en dessous et op vous me rappelez quand
vous pouvez
donc un problème de commande de vol
[Applaudissements]
vous repartez pour la vente c'est une
couche
alors là ce qui s'est passé c'est donc
le pilote automatique n'avait pas c'est
quoi lie pas les bonnes infos que ce qui
se passe ce qu'il y avait probablement
alors il était sur pilote automatique
parce que on entend le bruit du pilote
automatique et se débrouille et à ce
moment là bas faut réagir pour reprendre
les commandes de l'avion donc ils ont
fait leur job tout simplement il ya une
bonne entente entre le contrôle et les
pilotes qu'on comprise ont dégagé le
terrain ça ressemble un petit peu alors
un beaucoup moins grave
remarquable à la remarquable réactions
des pilotes vous avez vu le film julie
peut-être c'est un petit peu ce à quoi
il a repris quelque chose qu'il a été
exceptionnel là on n'est pas du tout
dans ce cas là on ça d'eux et pas mal
parce que les passagers ont eu peur et
c'est normal on dit que 95% des
passagers vos peurs les 5 % sont des
inconscients mais en tous les cas elle
est passée ils ont failli atterrir et là
ils ont vu repartir donc on est comme ça
on reprend 12 degrés d'assiette ce à peu
près ça ça fait quand même une sacrée
rotation on est un peu tassé sur le
siège mais franchement c'est pas
dangereux quoi on n'était pas là et non
le sait pas c'est pas parce que vous
êtes dans l'avion
c'est absolument et en plus ça c'est
important ça m'est arrivé une fois
c'était un terrain difficile à bogota
moi j'étais instructeur j'avais un un
pilote est on arrivé trop vite et c'est
donc une remise de gaz et ben il faut
pas attendre de prévenir les passagers
en disant tu en a remis les gaz c'est
pas grave on va se pointer si les s'il
n'avait pas repris contrôle de l'avion
là nourrit un crash alors oui à un
moment à un moment si on laisse faire
l'avion c'est sûr que celui-ci fait
n'importe quoi et comment le mouvement
le pilote qui voit que les calculs sont
mauvais comment ça se passe pardon
comment ils se rencontrent le commandant
le pilote de l'avion qui était non
contrôlée ou alors il l'a il a repris il
a surpassé le pilote automatique avec
force et là bas il a débrayé où le
pilote automatique s'est débrouillé les
deux hypothèses il sont paniqués
l'allier bas paniquer non je pense qu'il
faut paniquer ils ont dû un moment stop
stop stop ça veut dire qu'on reprend les
commandes à la main probablement là
maintenant qu'est ce qui va se passer on
va analyser les boîtes noires avec tous
les centaines de paramètres qui sont là
dessus on va écouter ce qu'on appelle le
cockpit voice recorders la conversation
entre les pilotes et savoir ce qui s'est
passé dans le cockpit on aura tous les
éléments parce que qu'est ce qu'on
cherche à faire il faut à tout prix
expliquer ce qui s'est passé à faire
pour prévenir les autres l'avion il ya
des centaines d'avions de même type pour
que ça se reproduise pas ailleurs
mathieu non à ce qui me choque moi j'ai
très très peur en avion la remise de gaz
c'est drôle ça m'est arrivé il ya un
mois affiné avec moi un simulateur bah
voilà est effectivement puisque la vue
on laisse poser un peu de travers ce qui
me dérange c'est pas ça ce qui me
dérange c'est me dire que on a beau me
dire tout ce qu'on veut qu'on soit à la
merci ben voilà d'un pilote automatique
qui finalement n'est pas si doux et ça
parce que il as cracher ou que la
fameuse pétition de pinto sur les
petites secondes qui sont l'avion qui
sont à l'avant à des avions c'était le
vole paris rio qui s'est écrasé enfin on
est quand même à la merci parfois d'une
technologie led et d'une baguette qui
est grande comme ça mais on a beau me
dire que c'est pas dangereux l'avion
bassal est la preuve c'est que ce pilote
automatique s'est planté oui c'est vrai
que quand on regarde moi je dis le
transport aérien je re oui mais c'est la
route qui mène à l'aéroport c'est pas
l'avion c'est ça veut rien dire vous
avez 400 fois plus
d'accidents en deux roues qu'en avion on
nous dit toujours ça mais ça nous
rassure pas moi j'ai fait tous les
stages je le dis dans l'équipe avec jura
j'adore gérardmer je suis passionné
justement par ce travail je suis très
admiratif parce que je me dis comment
peut on faire son métier et moi j'ai
fait tous les stages les stages air
france les ya d'autres stages qui
existent mais ça passe pas du tout jouer
à fond et j'ai vu alors c'est justement
le président question est ce que il ne
faudrait pas que à l'atterrissage on
arrête le pilotage automatique est ce
que finalement elle a non seulement on
n'arrête pas mais c'est obligatoire
accor de se poser en automatique si
l'aéroport équipé pour ça en cas de
brouillard un crac brouillard vous ne
voyez pas la piste vous pouvez vous
poser mais c'est obligatoire d'avoir
deux pilotes automatiques d'ailleurs
parce qu'ils discutent entre eux et vous
êtes à tout moment capable de reprendre
le pilote automatique si ça se passe mal
vous voyez pas là pis au dernier moment
vous remettez les gars vous débrayer le
paiera on appelle le pilote automatique
et vous repartez alors ya michel est
formé pour ça ok celle qui à 75 ans
était hier dans le business class dans
la business class du tall là témoigne
elle raconte il y avait énormément de
brouillard on a vu la piste dernier
moment on était quasiment sur la piste
quand l'avion est remonté extrêmement
vite moi je pensais qu'il avait raté son
atterrissage et en plus il y aurait pu
avoir une une double catastrophe puisque
en plus d'un crash éviter une collision
avec un autre avion a été également
éviter le contrôleur aérien qui a
compris que l'avion en provenance de new
york de dévier vers la gauche le temps
d'ordonner un autre avion alors en plein
décollage de stagner à 1500 pieds pour
ne pas entrer en collision avec l'autre
vol alors ça c'est le sait le job
classique du contrôleur il est là pour
500 écrans 10 ans il ya des trajectoires
qui risque d'être conflictuelle je les
écarte les arrête je limite en altitude
quand vous allez aux états unis un
terrain comme new york ou
philadelphie ça arrive de partout et les
contrôleurs ont bien l'habitude de ça en
plus à bord sur nos instruments on voit
les autres avions si jamais il ya une
défaillance du côté du contrôle alors je
vais bien on est capable de reprendre la
main cours alors
je vous donner des chiffres pour vous
rassurer
un accident mortel survient tous les 5
million de vols c'est ça la voiture
c'est 72 fois plus dangereux le
moustique est mille fois plus meurtriers
il ya autant de chances de gagner le
jackpot au loto que de mourir en avion
un passager devrait prendre l'avion tous
les jours pendant 123 millions avant de
mourir dans un crash c'est ça
c'est sûr défenseur du transport et il
est trois conseils pour augmenter les
chances de survie être assis à l'arrière
de la non
de chiottes il faut tracer l'arrière
écouté les consignes de sécurité ça peut
paraître chiant pour beaucoup de monde
mais je vous dis c'est important voilà
lors du crash d'un vol ethiopian
airlines 196 de nombreux passagers sont
restés coincés dans l'avion à cause de
leur gilet de sauvetage gonflé trop tôt
ils sont morts noyés
c'est fou et portait des vêtements en
coton pourquoi les vêtements poteaux
sont nettement moins inflammables que
les matières synthétiques sa larible
donc les manches longues et pantalons
sont des protections supplémentaires les
baskets voilà
avec qui permettent d'évacuer vitaux
sont généralement moins de 90 secondes
voilà donc
oui on doit évacuer les passagers du
même côté de l'avion en 90 secondes
alors on fait des essais en réel avant
de certifier l'avion on met 500 clan pas
là dedans et on leur dit alarme vous
descendez et il ya un chronomètre on dit
l'avion est certifié pas qu'on l'ait pas
de talons hauts pour éviter de crever
les toboggans d'évacuation aussi voilà
donc un joli